on
jardin en hiver à toi cet homme
extra
dans le temple est leur donne du pain
ils remuent leur dernière en dix ans
une voix
aussi des statues qui s'était fracturé
besson
on dit ça mais moi je sais que dès la
nuit venue
s'en vont sur le gazon chardat
extraordinaire fut rien les oiseaux du
fait du fort des dunes
petit morceau de brûler comme clients
ils ont soupé faut pas le dire bien
trouvé
c'est prévu pour aller tous vis au
niveau tarif ali n'est retrouvé a lieu
pour la promenade
j'avoue que ça me l'a fait
as tu pas par hasard d'adam dans ce
jardin extraordinaire
loin d'avoir fini mes passages cloutés
je donne les deux mêmes nos écrans de
petite grenouille la chasse en une
chanson pour saluer la lune d'excès
petit paru tout rond
émotion 20 20 je crois me serais fait
pas de distinction joie cela passer la
plus belle des filles alba avec moi
attention
sa manière brunet zemmour j'aime les
modes de vie et en sorte d'amener
maintenant fallait bien trouver dans cet
avis et reverse partie amour elle un
petit flirt de 20 ans
tu as oublié
les partisans dans l'ancien jardin
mais robin r non
l'agent tout est dedans mais vous sur la
perte meyer genou jour et du phosphate
en chef d'un jour
c'est pourquoi françois rémois la
douceur
il cherche est secret musée où vit au
fond du bois à chiens ou ceux qui
veulent savoir un programme ou sur son
île et vous voyez au coeur notre chanson
qui veulent parfois il pour la touche
plus ou moins de 20 grammes et prouve il
suffit pour ça d'un peu d'imagination
pour l'accoucheur ont su jour pappas
imagination tu prends comme un peu
d'imagination un jardin extraordinaire
comme un bond extraordinaire avec par
exemple pas du tout d'imprésario pas dit
ou de métro boulot dodo avec ça comme
avec cloclo avec lydie et sans impôt sur
12 ont besoin d'attention aux odeurs
il suffit pour ça un peu d'imagination